if and only if the exclusive or of A and B is equal to the logical and of X and Y.
That may be a little bit easier to digest if we express those conditions
in the form of a table as you see right here.
In the first column, we have the four possible question pairs, and in the second column we
have the conditions on A and B
that are required for
Alice and Bob to win.
In the first three cases,
the and of A and Y is zero, so the exclusive or must be equal to zero
in order for them to win,
and that's the same thing as saying that A and B must be equal because A and B are bits,
and the fourth case,
the and of X and Y is equal
to one and so the exclusive or of A and B must be equal to one in order for Alice and Bob to win
and that's the same thing
as saying that A and B must be different.
So, that's the CHSH game, and now we can think about
different possible strategies for Alice and Bob and how
well they can do in this game.
Let's start by thinking about
deterministic strategies where Alice's answer A is a
function of the question X that she receives, and
likewise, Bob's answer B
is a function of the
question Y that he receives.
And as it turns out, no
deterministic strategy can possibly win every time.
One way to reason that is
simply to go one by one through all of the possible
deterministic strategies and to check that every one of them loses
for at least one of the four
possible question pairs.
Alice and Bob, each have
four possible functions to choose from, we saw those
four functions in lesson one, so there are 16 possibilities
to check overall.
Another way to see that is to
think about the equations here on the screen, we're thinking
about deterministic strategies
where A and B are functions
of X and Y respectively.
So for example, A of zero
represents Alice's answer when her question X is equal to zero and a of one represents Alice's answer
when her question X is equal to one.
These are the four equations
that have to be true in order for the winning
conditions to be met in each of the four cases.
For example, if X is equal to
zero and Y is equal to zero, then the exclusive or of A
and B must be equal to zero,
whereas in the case that X is equal to one and Y is equal to one, the
exclusive or of A and B must be equal to one.
One way we can see that
there's no way to choose the functions A and B so that
these equations are all true, is simply to take the exclusive
or of all of the equations.
The exclusive or of any
binary value with itself is equal to zero, and so it follows that the exclusive or
of the left-hand sides
is equal to zero, that's
because we have two instances of a zero, two instances of a one,
two instances of B zero
and two instances of B one.
So, xing them all together
gives us the final answer of zero, but if we take the exclusive or of the right hand sides of the equations,
we get one not zero. So the four equations
can't possibly all be true, at least one of them has to be wrong
and that will lead to a
loss for Alice and Bob in at least one of the four cases.
And so it follows because the referee chooses the questions
uniformly that the probability for Alice and Bob to win
using a deterministic strategy
is at most three quarters or 75%.
The fact that Alice and and Bob can win with probability three quarters is quite easy to see
actually, if Alice and and Bob both answer zero all
the time, for instance,
they'll be correct three
out of the four times.
So Alice and Bob can't do
any better than winning 75% of the time using a
deterministic strategy.
But what about a probabilistic strategy?
Well, it turns out that using
a probabilistic strategy can't help them at all, that's because every
probabilistic strategy
can alternatively be viewed
as a random selection of a deterministic strategy just like probabilistic
operations can be viewed
as random selections of
deterministic operations, as we saw in the first lesson.
The average is never
larger than the maximum, so it follows that a
probabilistic strategy doesn't offer any advantage
in terms of winning
over a deterministic strategy. This even includes the possibility that Alice and Bob's random
choices are correlated.
So, the bottom line is that winning with probability three quarters is the best that Alice
and Bob can possibly do using any classical strategy,
whether it's deterministic
or probabilistic.
The natural question to ask at this point is whether Alice and Bob can do any better using a quantum strategy,
and in particular
if they share an entangled quantum state which they could have repaired
prior to playing the game, can that help them?
The answer is yes, it can, and that is the point of the example and that's why it's so interesting.
So let's see exactly how
Alice and Bob can do better in this game using entanglement.